hey guys quick update on the code tech
and tutorials channel
it's going to be a short one i just want
to run by some updates because i know
some of you are kind of wondering what's
going on and
that sort of thing so i just kind of
want to lay out a few things of what's
been going on for the last
week where my thought process has been
and the plans for the future
because i think i figured it out
so basically over the last week i've
just been doing a lot of different
research and exploring a lot of
different directions
i got pretty heavily intelligent because
you've been working on mostly just been
doing a lot of a lot of research
on different programming stuff code i've
just kind of recommitted to the code
so in my personal life i gave up a few
of my other hobbies
that i had been attending to so i can
spend more time
basically coding so give me that spicy
spicy memory management
you know coding takes a lot of time and
a lot of commitment it's one of those
things where if you just kind of go
about it haphazardly you'll progress
very slowly quick updates on the patreon
i have paused
the august payments so no one's going to
get charged
and i did this because i'm going to make
patreon a more special thing
and with these limited slots i'm going
to offer things like tutoring one-on-one
help and and things like that for like
the big slots but they've got to be
limited because of like a ton of people
sign up i can't make that kind of
commitment because i do want to be able
to spend time with people that want help
maybe they just want a tutor or
something so it's going to be more for
that kind of stuff
and you may have noticed this channel
now has like memberships and
join and all the super chat and stuff so
we're going to be getting some special
emotes and things like that
and that's going to be mainly replacing
the patreon
as it used to be so the new patreon will
probably start about a month
or i got to figure out a schedule where
i can commit to
the people who sign up i don't want it
to feel like an actual job i just want
this to be something i actually want to
do
so the bottom line is i have to change
my business model because this one isn't
working for me i'm sure i did have the
issue with my eye
earlier in the month but that's pretty
much over now other than there's a
little bit of blurriness and you
probably need to get your glasses
also haven't made as many videos because
the ones i'm supposed to make i don't
feel like making
all the stuff i feel like making i
haven't made because i feel bad because
i'm not making the ones i should be
making and it's it's kind of
it's becoming a vicious cycle where i
feel like the way it's actually
currently set up is kind of hurting me
more than it's helping me so
we're gonna use the membership and join
stuff instead and for you guys to get
special stuff
i will do some membership videos here
and there there's already one up there
of the the day in the life 5k sub thing
i
i took it off public because i felt like
it was just too personal and just too
much
there's just too much personal stuff i
have a lot of regrets about that video
honestly i even cut like half of it
i should have cut another half of it and
left it down like 10 minutes or
something because
geez i really uh special members can
watch it it's fine
i just don't want the general public
necessarily watching it forward to more
stuff and tutorials and code and i hope
this
change sits with you guys i understand
it's not going to for everyone like
it's just how change works some people
are going to love it some people are
going to hate it
i really hope that everybody loves it
and thinks it's better i think it's
better it's definitely better for me
i've decided that
i guess that's it let's look at a few
memes a little uh little and special
here
instagram she likes her own pictures
haha
read it automatically upload your own
post stack overflow you can't vote for
your own post
keeping a real stack overflow all right
when you start seeing your worth you'll
stop seeing people who don't
that's not really coding me but great
advice nonetheless
yeah see your own worth you guys are way
more valuable than you think
time is absolute isaac newton time is a
relative albert einstein
time is defined by the number of seconds
that have elapsed since january
whatever okay this is an old meme isn't
it yep that's what it is
and programming gotta represent it
somehow i don't know why i saved this
meme i guess i thought it was funny at
the time but now i just think it's kind
of like
okay mustache position bottom align
center
the bottom stash epic
there are too many people too much greed
too many problems definitely too many
javascript libraries
all right that's the memes that i have
saved look forward to some more videos
i'm just gonna do them as i see fit
kind of you know at this at this point
all right peace out guys
[Music]
you